if you look at influencer marketing
there are millions making a hundred
thousand years so many of these markets
are winner take all markets on the
platform side what do you mean Google
Facebook Tick Tock I'm sorry about on
the individual side no on the individual
side the long tail of creators extremely
long it's winner take all if you define
success a million dollars if you define
success eighty thousand dollars it's
astonishing and I keep telling a lot of
my corporate friends and leaders you're
worried about the great resignation wait
till you see the great never applying in
the first place you've got an entire
generation of kids growing up on Roblox
Tick Tock fortnite who are like I could
work at IBM or vaynermedia or whatever
or I can make 61k doing X Y and Z I'll
keep building maybe I get to 200k and it
is a blind spot to The Establishment at
scale and so what we talk about is these
kids are entitled they're not entitled
they're aware of their options